all right people it's here today is one
of the biggest
online shopping days of the year every
year amazon hosts prime day which is
actually a
two-day sales event with major deals and
this year it is expected to be even
busier than 2020
with 30 to 35 percent more online
traffic
other retailers are also stepping up
turning this week into a summer shopping
frenzy that rivals black friday
and cyber monday our consumer
investigative correspondent
anna werner compares the different deals
amazon prime day is here
and with it big savings on some commonly
discounted products in home goods and
electronics like luna gaming controllers
the latest echo buds and echo show
devices
alexa show me my to-do list but you may
also see bargains in less usual
categories like
fashion and luggage says cnets share in
profits
we expect consumers to spend on things
that will help them do
activities that they weren't able to do
over the past year
so things like things like camping
dining out clothing those are products
that really haven't seen a lot of action
over the past year
and we expect to be popular over prime
day and in addition to featuring its own
products
amazon will be showcasing products
coming from small businesses
shoppers can filter their search to find
local businesses
in categories including black owned
woman owned and military family owned
stores
i think they're realizing that consumers
care
fariha ali with digital commerce 360
believes
amazon is responding to public criticism
i think
amazon is facing a lot of backlash in
the last couple years
of either being a monopoly or
hurting smaller businesses so i think
they have to care because consumers care
most traffic online still goes to amazon
during prime day
but other major retailers are gunning
for them with competing sales
walmart is running a four-day deals for
days promotion on items including roku
tvs for over 20 percent off
and hp chromebooks down 10 percent and
best buy kohl's and target are in the
game too
with sales items including dyson vacuums
over 30 percent off
and 50 percent off instant pot pressure
cookers
even with competition amazon captured
nearly 40 percent of online sales
traffic last year
and generated 10 billion dollars in
sales for the company
they're still the behemoth in online
retail
but recent controversies have prompted
some shoppers to say they won't be
shopping on prime day
a recent new york times investigation
described arduous working conditions at
amazon warehouses
and advocacy groups like green america
want consumers to also think about the
environmental consequences
of all those online purchases the groups
charlotte tate those products need to be
shipped across the world if they're not
made in the u.s so
that shipping process has a
environmental impact
i would love for amazon to shrink its
carbon footprint
have less waste but also for amazon to
respect workers rights
well in response amazon says that it's
committed to building a sustainable
business for customers and the planet
and the company says it's made
significant progress at reducing carbon
emissions
amazon says it's buying electric
vehicles and it's also prioritizing
investments that help to fight the
climate crisis anthony yeah lifeline for
a lot of people during the pandemic
though i will say that when that was the
only way you could get anything yeah and
anthony and i are both big fans of that
vacuum cleaner
that was a nice deal yeah it was a nice
deal all right anna thank you